[Music]
you know when I was a kid my dad drove a
a $500 bread truck into our driveway and
I thought we were going into the bread
business and he said no this is our
camper I said I can read it says Morita
bread and rolls on the side of the truck
and over that time where we built bunk
beds it flipped down we made a sofa we
plumbing a propane tank into a Coleman
stove we rewired the entire truck over
this time I learned how to be an
engineer and I was in middle school
so experiential learning it wasn't until
we painted the side of the truck that I
realized we're going to Myrtle Beach
South Carolina or vacation in this
recreational vehicle
so experiencial learning whether it
comes from home school wherever you get
it boys and girls club but we have to
give kids meaningful things to do with
their hands and give them problems that
can help you know solve problems in your
community or in the world and not just
do make work stuff and I think when we
when we let them build and create and in
it in its meaningful and it helps them
solve a problem that gives some thinking
about how they can be change makers
themselves and how they can be
scientists and engineers because that's
what they're doing and they're thinking
creatively and they're solving problems
and that's what we do is as engineers
and scientists and so get them get them
early building and creating things that
are meaningful like I built the bread
truck that you know save the day for us
and we'd have to spend twenty four
thousand dollars on a Winnebago
when we have a five hundred dollar bread
truck this serves the same purpose
getting the family in the cheapest way
possible to a destination so that the
family can explore these new
surroundings the intellectual side of
learning and the physical side of
learning how are they connected and what
does that interplay and I think Lego has
done a really great job of teaching kids
to play with these bigger Duplo blocks
or the bigger box where they're trying
to move them from one side of the body
to the other side because if you split
the brain as you're going across the
brain you are now making this physical
space connection with both sides of your
brain and and they're their players
intentional to have kids to do that at a
very
and so understanding how my body works
how I turn in twist and jump when I'm
catching a pass has the same effect as
me working hand controllers on the
International Space Station moving the
the two billion dollar Columbus
laboratory out of the payload Bay of the
shuttle
and attaching it to the space station I
have to know how to position my body in
zero-gravity where I'm not you know
floating off and I'm gonna put in the
wrong you know hand controller motion
that's gonna slap the thing in the side
of the space station and kill the
project and maybe kill us so body mine
spatial reasoning body spatial reasoning
are all connected to solving problems
and you know you have these foot straps
you put your feet in to keep you from
you know translating around but still
you have to react off the hand control
it's just like you do off the off the
foot straps and I think you know
understanding your body in space as well
as on the ground helps you do these
technical things that are that are
challenging with your body
[Music]